we're back saying you own a lot of the
wood I have to ask you to hobbit an
unexpected journey okay I was wondering
you reprised your role you came back to
do the role same set obviously Peter
Jackson but you had to watch Martin
Freeman live in your house and I was
wondering if on some level because I
know you and we've talked about it
before you inhabited that character so
much and it was so important to you that
seeing another person sitting and living
in your home I wonder if in any way that
felt weird to you
very strange yeah it was very strange I
mean the reality is I never expected to
go back to middle-earth I never expected
to play that character again so to go
back and then be on that set again it
was the weirdest feeling it was a
combination of traveling back in time
and also the strangest thing was that it
felt like no time had passed I was
standing there and Pete like popped
around the corner to give me a direction
and I thought I feel like it was only
yesterday that I was there right and
then there's Martin Freeman sharing my
house and there were upgrades there was
a there were new rooms right before
there was a pantry did that embittered
that suddenly his house was now he has
[Laughter]
2.0 and the thing that was crazy is
before so for the Lord of the Rings if
people know we had this Hobbit feet
right we had to have them glued on it
took about an hour and a half every day
it was a bit of a painful process kind
of annoying we were really psyched on
days we didn't have to put the feet on
well in the whatever 10 years that had
passed they figured out a way that you
could just slip them on so I come on to
this movie for like three days of work
and they're like slipping their feet on
like yeah you would get to do like so
back in my day
when I paid a hobbit things were
different it's precisely what it was you
don't know how easy you got it you kids
today with your pantries and your
slip-on feet
[Laughter]